hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray okay alright
Vani
welcome back to the fold Orchestra
welcome back okay so we just finished up
in the last episode exploring and
finding a bunch of hidden areas and
getting things unlocked and getting
things explored but now we're gonna be
going straight into the gut system and
in the guts aside hey
hello oh ah oh okay
why what did that happen oh man that
thing is still in there oh I don't want
to mess with that I tried to mess with
that out in space and it didn't go so
well for me I'm pretty sure that just
goes back to the other yeah the live
exam or a morgue so oh my god oh my god
they just exploded oh my god
oh they didn't oh they didn't explode
there was a turn there oh never mind
then okay alright auto turrets trans
stars last-ditch defense against an
outbreak Oh Lindsay but they're easy to
fabricate best part is the built-in
psycho scope tech they can discriminate
between alien and human targets
shouldn't be a problem for you since
you're not an alien since I'm not an
alien yet you got always leave room for
improvement in the future okay but we're
going right into the guts and then we're
gonna be able to fly all the way up to
the Arboretum and then we'll be able to
go over there and find that body that
we've been looking for since the
beginning of the game I can't believe it
let me so far down the road before I was
actually going to be able to find that
body what now that we have that and the
ability to get up there I believe that's
correct anyway I might be wrong about
that but if you look on the station map
yeah I am currently in the guts and the
guts run straight up to the Arboretum so
let's do dis oh hi how are you oh but I
don't need you right now I might as well
might as well get the experience out of
it and what I need to do is I need to
get the dismantle ability because if I'm
gonna fight more of these robots then
I'm definitely gonna need to take the
spare parts but I mean wait I'm not
going to be able to use the spare parts
unless I'm going to have the repair
ability because I have the most basic
level of repairs but I don't have a
hundred percent repair
oh this is necessary thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you hello Laurel there
comes a time in every man's life when he
looks for towards the future our futu
Laurel would you do me the honor of
accepting this proposition of affection
and stupid stupid yeah I mean I'm not
one to give advice on how to date girls
but that doesn't seem like the correct
way sure
all right fine then the electrical fault
is still an issue in subsection 19 when
will the replacement electrical
components be available so I can finally
get this repair under way you understand
I cannot leave this subsection offline
at all times correct meanwhile having to
navigate around the fan vents is not
ideal parts are on the way love climb
climb Wi-Fi you're gonna be fine don't
worry about it all right
I've got a lot of junk to get rid of and
I'm also gonna get rid of this which I
don't need cuz it's an extra ah I love
this hunters bowl Kassar though I don't
mean don't use it but I got it oh and I
got six neuro mods okay so that's all
good I'm gonna hold onto that as a
memento because I'm weird and then that
should be enough so with that being said
I should have an that and then I'll be
able to craft stuff later where did you
go hi I've got four points of damage can
you stick your [ __ ] like you gave me a
good lick down below and huh I'm not
gonna lie I liked it it was good ha ha
oh hello I got to remember how to fly
hello sorry Eric
hi how you doing well I guess I didn't
need to spawn an engineer when you just
gave me another one though these rules
run the entire length of the station and
mostly Chloe would carrying the bare
necessities our water dare operators
also use it to deliver supplies from the
cargo bay up to the Arboretum
even the small number of crew assigned
here I would expect - presence to be
minimal as well
now I don't have that assumption yes but
this is probably a bad assumption if
this is gonna get all 100% dead space up
in this B right then we're gonna have a
lot more of the enemies around here so
the things that I need is I need repair
to and then eventually I need dismantle
but I can't get both I need one more
neuroma before I'm able to do both and I
would probably want to get the materials
expert also because I need so much more
damage than that wrench specialization
yeah I want to do that but now I'm gonna
get dismantle for now because that means
I'm gonna be able to get more spare
parts right immediately and then later
on when I have things that I need to
repair I'll be able to use them as thus
suchly so let's go up I forgot now to
fly I've completely forgotten how to fly
I'm sorry everybody I have no idea what
I'm doing with my life all right let's
go
fast too fast way to fats out it's up
there that even you can't go flying by
this too quickly Oh take that and you
can just shut up
take that all right is that all the
stuff that was here welven there was
gonna be more of that but okay I guess
I'll take what I can get and then scan
doodly-doo over to the Arboretum
oh there's key why oh I don't know what
that is hey let's get ice candy huh okay
what happened oh ah January was very
wrong did I mention that I don't trust
January like at all I think that January
killed December in December was like an
earlier clone of my brain oh [ __ ] okay I
guess that's perfectly normal except for
all the other things that are over here
all right
hello hi I'm going to scan you
apparently wait how do I cancel this
f-from go scan you scare anybody but can
I stop ah cystoid nest oh yeah Scott
lasya oh oh that is Oh see you that is
shockingly effective like that is
legitimately shockingly effective oh can
i scan you before I blast you into
oblivion whoa boy oh there's a lot of
you okay good
assist ID from the sister nest I'm
guessing oh it's gonna oh damn you oh
did I get him I don't know if I got him
but I should blue the heck out of that
thing
alright there's one up there but I'm I'm
I guess I'm okay
those noises I don't like but I'm gonna
just get Adil on by because I think I'm
okay look at that
you be boom oh I love that screw being
human pill [ __ ] uh it's gonna be what I
didn't get any of you oh okay I don't
understand exactly how you guys are
functioning but I don't like it I think
I'm fire what digits panicking from
being on fire they on fire something
okay
use a sigh hypo don't think I got tons
of those things oh I need to eat - all
right let's try blow you okay
surprisingly effective let's get out of
here before I get radiated this is so
cool hi am I supposed to go down there
yup D Oh looks like I am unless I can
hang this second yeah that's a hackable
all right okay it's good OOP D mmm
really Luthi where am I Oh far away yeah
this is not gonna mess with me because I
am an expert
hahahaha
no that one ah Frick offering offering
all free Oh Frick come on no oh god no
I've never failed a hack oh god damn it
what are you gonna shock me for that
I've never failed a hack before I'm
sorry under cloudy I feel like I've
failed you all personally it's just
utter disgrace that one was a tough one
this one is way easier by comparison oh
that was super easy we're gonna lose or
am i all right we're gonna keep moving
who week anyway well that got nobody oh
god that is like a lot of you guys you
just move last up oh that's quite a calm
bro this this power is my favorite this
is my favorite thing oh yeah you all
exploded I don't understand fully how
you exploded but you exploded electrical
sub-section okay okay okay electrical
subsection 19 fault detected well I
think we knew about that because they
were talking about that on the on the
email oh is it that we're talking about
who I'm gonna leave those alone
I can't repair that because I don't have
the repair skill but I can go down here
ooh well that's convenient well that's
really convenient so I don't actually
need to go into my thing be able to get
a sign yeah why are you all still alive
Jesus
okay well that's some of them hey hold
still trying to glue you look you so you
don't explode on me
I know exploders when I see him and you
guys look like a bunch of sploders haha
what the [ __ ] they just don't stop okay
that doesn't work let's try something
else here oh there we go
one more blasters boom oh hey hit myself
oh well I think I got him
alright skidooed Lee it's gonna at least
kanuda Lee alright
there's what they were talking about
going through the vents it's not ideal
we didn't seem that bad
Oh what the [ __ ] is happening the [ __ ]
is Amy Morgan steady
that pulse hit your suit systems pretty
hard it came from the substation ahead
oh there's a magnetosphere around Talos
one that keeps the Sun from cooking your
insides Oh
generator isn't done uh-huh hopefully
we'll be fine
oh yeah good that's what I wanted to
know you'll be fine oh that makes me
feel so much better
oh man it's got so many spare parts
around here and a little little
miscellaneous pieces of [ __ ]
floating everywhere if I was less lazy I
wouldn't come after these things but I'm
so so so so tempted to go for him okay
so what was that about a big old
magnetosphere boiling my insides what
was that about that what was that about
that is that something bad that I should
worry about oh I see okay restrictive
access see Anders Klein in the
magnetosphere control room okay oh all
right I'll go into the thing that's
gonna boil my insides and here I thought
well just get out scot-free and I would
have my insides not boiled oh jeez got
stopped floating oh all right
okay splat great thank you I didn't even
see that all right what have we got here
oh hello where did you come from
engineer patch up my suit please I don't
really need it but if you could do it a
little bit thank you oh hi all right
either Oh dead body oh that's nice how
does that notice that before
cuz I'm stupid yeah it's probably the
answer we-we-we so glad I go through a
whole bunch of chromatic aberration
after that that's how to be good for my
insides which are about to cook because
of the thing that they mem I think my
lung has got a good hit from that one oh
hi hello are you the guy I'm supposed to
see are you mr. Anders Oh your suits
miss to be leaking ma'am where's the
leak ma'am oh boy alright hello dad Oh
what who's dead Anders I tried to go on
security I tried to need a medical team
take a deep breath uh-huh sorry I'm
sorry
Anders went into the mag chamber to test
what a coiled hopefully hi hello I don't
know what happened exactly but oh god
I'm so sorry can you get up to the
Arboretum no Anders have the key card
okay got it listen just sit tight don't
go into that chamber I'm gonna find she
fellas re we got a security team your
way ASAP okay well that sounds bad so
that's why that guy died in the air
because it cooked his insides
as the more Drax screamed flare crumpled
to the ground in front of her mercy
flexed her fingers they ached from ulta
choking oh this is mercy from overwatch
Trevor rounded the corner behind her
phase pistol still smoking the cries of
the moor Drax hot on his heels mercy
granted I don't get it Trevor
why did you spring me from this kill
prison I've tried to offer you like
seven times
Trevor reply between blasts of his
pistol because you're the only one who's
come close to killing me another blast
Wham and you're the only one I can trust
we're gonna steal the star bender prism
out from under Prince argon snows mercy
could only smirk her fingers were for
her Stranglers we're feeling better
already
it's gonna go for a mean stranglin oh
yeah
mercy strangling that's hilarious okay
let me open this one ah good I didn't
start from a bajillion miles away come
on stop bouncing like a goof oh you're
gonna put that of a jillion miles away
though can you stop bouncing like a goof
like I requested hobo Duke Bennett are
give me your sweet sweet innards even I
got a lot of weapon upgrades kit but I'm
not actually able to upgrade any further
because I mean how would I don't have
any weapon goo
Hey Oh talk about shock wave ohh-ho
goodness gracious gravy me gee will
you're Batman
oh I missed I missed Baba ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba
where are you irradiated you guys suck
so much ah in the fire Oh God
out of the frying pan into the fire you
guys suck
what's with you guys let me enjoy hustle
I'm about to die
[ __ ] you're not dead how are you not
dead Jesus you guys are [ __ ] this
isn't even in zero Jamin I'm dealing
with you douche nozzles Oh frickin ass
back soon okay yeah shockwaves in a
minute oh you're alive I will bash ever
lucky [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you okay
should be clear
alright so anything else in here I need
okay so I'm assuming that guy is the key
card where's there you are hi okay hello
oh god please don't don't don't
run don't run for me ah yes good I got
high post Geyer there anything else in
there I need anything else in here I
need anything anything anything I don't
see anything I don't see anything I
don't see anything I don't see supplies
wait supplies we're supplies you say
supplies uh-huh I got you higher oh no
oh no I'm trying it's real hard to
navigate
oh no the hole geez yeah okay I was fine
I had plenty of time you just made to
see oh hi hi whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa yeah you get [ __ ]
wrecked and end up firing up [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of here science operator
hey hey hey get down yeah that's right
okay thank you for that signs can you
give me my scoop Deeb is back I don't
what are you doing here ah oh
ah I'm sorry I'm really sorry about the
how I'm really sorry that was not my
intention
got a kick oh [ __ ] you
fine then oh it's gonna grab all the
stuff I'm not going to worry about
putting the fire like a responsible nor
all ah
alrighty then shoot there we go that's
better about it okay
I don't know why did I bother doing I
thought it was gonna put out the fires
ourselves
I'm such a goof I'm such a gosh darn
goof then I blew up the science operator
that was actually gonna be able to help
me with this stuff but cool anything in
there
gonna get any of that somehow nah okay
fine then it's connealy do good old
microgravity so I got the keycard to the
Arboretum
alright you're sigh is low ah I should
restore this but I won't is I've got
another objective to do just deal with
over here hello oh good great one of
this stuff you're not
okay alrighty then
well I think that just confirmed my
theories I am NOT human but I don't even
think I don't even think I'm Morgan you
who was human ecology appears to be
centered around the creation of this
substance the original researchers
called it coral beautiful but we're not
sure what its purpose is but you do it's
never spread outside the containment
cylinder until now uh-huh
okay why would you call it beautiful
that's a very human thing to call
something all right I've got a theory
it's a bit far-fetched it's pretty out
there but I've got a theory I don't
think I'm human I think I am an
experiment to troll wait well way well
we whoa whoa whoa how about you get
flapped
whoa that's a Weaver
that's a Weaver I'm going to scan you
mr. Feeny no aw dad that's that's the
opposite of what I want
Hey okay all right that's uh okay I got
it back class - I don't know what that
is
Oh Lily whoa okay you know what what
happens if I just sprint by them ah ha
ha flying in zero-g is pretty hard I'm
gonna grab you oh Jesus radioactive why
is he radioactive hello hello okay fine
you do what you can do
hey he's trying to repair this whole
place by himself whoa [ __ ] is going on
compromised
therapy the power plant is in
compromised it's about
I'm saying chief I'm not a ComTech I'm
doing the best I can
Myka this is security chief Eleazar
can you hear me Sarah yes I can you been
trying to patch into the PA my team's in
the cargo bay and those things are in
here too
they're crawling all over the station
check everything around you keep it with
a wrench check the wrench first Sam
he's right these things smash every
freestanding thing and see if it comes
back at you get to a secure area and
when you're safe call me by a transcribe
I'm sending you a secure contact all
right understood love my son sky
chemical origin insertion heading that
map I can work myself in are you okay
and just catching my breath
like I get safe then cold okay so this
is really weird cuz there are other
people that are alive on this station
that are fighting but that person
sounded sick maybe from some sort of an
infection caused by these things
okay these are dead very dead that's not
the person who was just talking
definitely uh it's so weird
God is so good and what are these eel
scraps what are you what not you what
are you uh I mean I could guess that
your eels but that would just be too
obvious in this edition of trance our
life's rising star segment we profile
Harley Granger a member of the neuro mod
sales team who is currently stationed
aboard Talos one some of you might
recognize Harley's name from his
professional baseball days when he
played second base at war number 66 for
the tornadoes Harley was assigned the
Talos one two years ago and has made the
journey into orbit and back over 50
times not bad for someone who is afraid
of flying my time playing baseball
forced me to deal with
that fear oh never mind I guess I see a
end of that story
believe it or not a shuttle flight to
Talos 1 is far easier than a
cross-country airliner trip ha ha oh ok
so that was fascinating but a little
more backstory in universe building
which I am not opposed to but we have
finally reached after all this time the
frickin Arboretum which means that we're
going to be able to go to the Arboretum
and then we're gonna be able to actually
do what we need to do I don't even know
what we need to do but we're gonna be
able to do it that's what I know for a
fact to let us see what the Arboretum
has in store for us daily delivery there
we go nor id2 or take the Arboretum got
it oh thank you thank you so much boy
[ __ ] goddamn entrance the team storage
is off the Arboretum your brother's
offices up here as well Jupiter in his
palace at the top of the heavens you
used to say that behind his back and
that would make you what Neptune Pluto
why do I get the feeling that you're
making fun of me I don't think I called
anybody anything all so yeah it's weird
like there's a suggestion that they're
talking to me like I have memories and
like I'm the original Morgan you so
there is that evidence but I can't help
but shake the feeling they set in that
flashback yeah this place about to
explode place about to explode Sloopy
yes please thank you
whoa ski
fabrication plan DRM does not matter
what I was afraid this might happen a
leading euro mod engineer Walden graves
in a kill switch in the license for
neural mod plans Jane
there was a solid engineer I think it
was suspicious of the more exotic
components you talking about the useless
workstations that we set the license you
talking about the aliens okay fine I get
it
I don't have the bright DRM that's a
scary thing about the future of DRM and
stuff like that that that literally is a
scary thing about the future oh my god I
get too many of these spare parts why
are these not stacking anymore what what
do they not stacking wait hey I'm
organized that thank you
I've got so many spare parts I could you
I don't know if that would be a bad idea
let me and let me do these let me do all
the junk first but I could ooh let me
split that down let me split that down
ah this might be a bad idea but now that
I got the dismantle ability right it
should be it it should be fine right
that I would be able to I'll be able to
sacrifice some of those and it should be
okay right
I think so if I'm wrong then I'm
terribly stupid but I believe that
actually is going to work out well for
me
yeah there's no reason why I wouldn't
I'm always gonna get more ya know maybe
so alright whatever I'm gonna assume
that's good enough for me
and that's gonna give me a lot more
material to be able to make bullets oh
yes the mineral material that's what I
really needed okay I get it can you move
on from that I I'm aware of that can I
get the shotgun shells in yes that's
what I needed
okay so that's another reason to have
that and then I know maybe also I can
get repair too and I have seven which
might just be enough to get extra
recycling yes it is I can get the extra
recycling and I can get the repair which
is both good and then maybe I can get
more lab tech so I'd get more weapon
upgrades that would be fine and dandy
okay that's good
that's actually legitimately good I mean
I do want to do more of the alien stuff
an electrostatic burst of electrostatic
resistance a coffee cup Oh phantom
genisys oh oh that died that doesn't
sound good
create a phantom out of a human corpse
that sounds like being the the overlord
of these beings just a little too much
that is that is just a little padieu
there but I'll focus on them now for now
and I'll just focus on that then maybe
just maybe we'll have everything that we
need later I'm gonna make nine
millimeters sure buddy wimpy and I'm
probably gonna run drying this but
anyway what I was saying about the
digital rights management of all this
stuff 3d printing is the future right
and no matter what you say like whatever
it is going to be the future of how
things are made they're even building
houses with 3d printing so when it comes
to just having these plans like
basically what it comes down to is just
a plan and a printer the whole concept
of fabrication on a large scale can be
replicated through everyone in their own
home having a 3d printer of this
magnitude now I'm not saying this is
going to happen in a few years it's like
right 50 years a way to get this level
of 3d printing but then digital rights
management how does that play into play
how can you stop people from pirating
like things that are very valuable in
terms of production costs like you want
to run that by me again the [ __ ] just
screamed at me Morgan are you alright
yeah fine
that tie Fionn there's nothing in the
research stay away from it I don't see
ya - oh there's other guys you worried
about over there some screaming cat like
oh hi does it come from over there
what did it do to you mark what'd it do
all right I guess there's no other way
to go I think I'm all out of stuff that
I need to salvage and build yeah I'm
doing pretty good I'll come back for
this later
hope you excuse me mark yeah but when
the future comes down to making
everything in your home who's gonna be
to look into why the lift is stuck it
would be a lot faster and safer than
having to fly through the guts again
yeah you know I kind of liked it you
know it was a nice relaxing true oh cool
whoa I saw you move why did you move
what the hell did you move you don't
need to get up for me
I mean come on why are all the displays
broken [ __ ] was that
okay what the [ __ ] was that hello can I
open you I feel I heard something
skittering over there whoa I don't like
any of this I don't like any of this
place I thought this place was gonna be
beautiful but now you're telling me
about Typhon that I need to stay away
from and I'm hearing skitter scatters
fine [ __ ] god damn it every [ __ ]
time
all right 5-minute Julian stopped by but
you were out FYI reviewed your lap notes
plans posed no health risk you should be
good to go in the Arboretum alright
thanks for that all right good morning
fellows morning tion up now I need to
know what's going on in this goddamn
forest before I lose my mind to
everything being dead again what the
hell is with these corpses these
perfectly okay adequate looking corpses
that look Apple oh no we got another
case of a head sploders if they look
fine in the dead think they're supposed
to be all warped in one knot but I
thought this for some reason I thought
this door was gonna open oh boy yep
someone is not okay over there ah but
it's so cool oh my god that's so pretty
ah oh it's the milky Wow
Oh God so beautiful Oh back alright fine
let's try to get in here I guess it's
not gonna do me much good to go in here
because I'm pretty sure is that oh wait
hey over here
open this door oh well um please can you
get it open
okay did you just curse him with the
heads floaty disease uh boy oh it looks
like a big mop of hair that's so weird I
was able to do it anyway so I guess I
didn't lollygag for nothing but uh okay
so alex is safe is up there to his
residence was in the Arboretum is he
good touchin is pleased with the hills
Oh Nova can I repair this I can yes
Italy doodly-doo my nail Ian
insufficient time and material found
standing down okay so I'm still human
enough to not get shot by you which is
always comforting alright let's see
hello yeah see this is the kind of Corp
what the [ __ ] hell
oh hi what are you doing over there
anyway this is the kind of course I
would but my statement seems to be a bit
me it is P hello what was moving around
in here oh I see okay so if I can fix
you
about gene Talos the time is no 12 um it
doesn't seem like it needs a repair I'll
repair three why are these better why in
the world is better
wait what is this gonna do huh tell us
one lobby do I need to go the lobby why
is the main lift all bar key then hey
let me go up to Alex's sweet before we
go there who medbay handy-dandy oh and
then indeed thank you Oh I can leverage
these and let me leverage these give me
some good stuff I feel bound Oh what is
it here is this another way into where I
was supposed to go or is this looking
into the elevator
mmm I owned and I did not mean that I'm
sorry oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I am sorry
I need to go back to thee oh I can't get
through there it's glass
wait it's glass no uh-huh please shoot
him shoot him shoot him shoot him shoot
him oh I see they're facing the wrong
way I'm just gonna take you and put you
right right here and wool I'm gonna
deploy that bad boy
can I scan you before you die inevitably
don't shoot him Dustin yes oh okay well
that didn't work out the way I was
hoping to do this but okay all right or
fair you Oh God I was standing in the
goop okay I don't need to do that
because there's a medbay right here and
you can fix me right the eff up where
did you go ah mm a med bay standing my
BAE the big guy go did he blow up you
just blow up and question I can think
there's another one in there rigged to
go come on heal me I'm so wounded I've
got her T's in my heart please
diagnosing yeah give me the good set
okay cool you can fill out a service
questionnaire at the front desk okay so
what's in here that I needed
is that not a camera or a light I have
no idea where am I why do they have this
whole area back here what's the purpose
ooh I got a chipset then why what's that
for you have a chance to cast aside
power for free huh well that's that
that's nice I guess that's a little more
useful than a speed scan I mean just to
be perfectly honest I don't want to say
too much about it
ooh reduces damage sustained while
sliding what what how much damage could
I possibly take while sliding I don't
even know what you're talking about wall
sliding what what am I gonna slide all
right whatever you know what I'm not
gonna question it too much I'm just
gonna do what I got to do and slide my
way to victory over here
skadoosh key oh so if they were
attacking me and I slid eed I'd be okay
uh I can't leverage that
I'm enough okay so is there any other
reason for being here besides this is
all borked oh no no oh this looks bad
maybe I can do something about this all
righty then put that out there's got to
be some reason that this is all kinds of
borked I put out that fire I don't know
if that had anything to do with the
inability of the elevator to go but
there must have been something that was
stopping me from actually going down
this elevator right it's not just what
it what it's fine why it's just fine but
it's fine
what do you mean it's just fine the hell
is that about the hell is that about
I didn't do anything okay well - is an
unknown type from what I can tell it's
the source of a problem with the lift oh
I get it phantom you unleashed in
psychotronics had similar disruptive
abilities believe this once there's more
power so you can get anymore
oh okay you know what I'm again I'm out
of here
okay I don't need to be here didn't need
to be there right then I'll fix the
problem when I get to that I gotta go
Daleks is room and see what happened
when December got blown to smithereens
by January up there and hopefully
hopefully I'm not going the wrong way
about this because I have funny feeling
that I'm not ready for that fight I
would love to think I was ready for that
fight but given now they just docked all
my health all in one where's that
goddamn Medical Officer medical robot
where did you go I need you right now I
am in medical need all right whatever it
doesn't matter so I gotta get up there
somehow in that illustrious lofty place
that is up on high crew quarters
whoo-hoo
alrighty then there's a medical operator
over there so if I someone was trying to
seal this off but it looks like they
didn't work
oh sorry whoa hey come on now
I was waiting for the medical officer
but you're gonna be a bit of a mirage
I'm gonna use my 100 bulken Oh gotcha
under that field
oh whoa okay all right you know what not
just about enough of your sass okay
never mind I'm gonna have to tolerate a
little more sass until I get this ready
to go are you real oh good new ski and
finishing shot there oh uh yeah yeah
god damn it Howie oh geez you all suck
so hard oh wait what am i doing I got I
got my own psychic attack for you yeah
how's that feel good uh hunch uh not so
good huh all right well what have we got
in there oh geez
someone is not a be in there the glue
cannon corpse materials where did that
guy go I know they didn't kill him with
one hit whatever
that's so weird the way they're saying
those things are just corrupting them
that's a bizarre an appointment ah
that's so weird why do they need that
we're all god I'm so far away you little
loopy ah Boinky okay f
Jesus oh Jesus okay got that one Jesus
that was a tough one
apparently not really okay stop stop
stop stop stop stop stop
beat the ever-loving get blown there you
go okay medical officer I'm gonna need
you why are there two of you boink boink
boink
okay let's get Adil away and then that's
how we finish them off
give me more spare parts yes please
please okay what was in here that I
needed those those ah here we go
this looks like something we'll get
things first in 1964 President Kennedy
turned his back on American invention
interventionism but what if America had
stood up for its allies in Vietnam would
communism still reign in the East with
the Iron Curtain have fallen renowned
politician commentator Lance B Jenkins
weaves a gripping alternate alternate
account of the days following the Gulf
of Tonkin incident and what might have
been if America had gone to war in 1964
ah so this is kind of important because
this says in this universe where the
timelines deviated cuz in 1964 we in our
universe went to war in Vietnam the US
did I'm talking about the United States
and for better for worse it did happen
so are you saying that we would be
dealing with the alien typhoons if we in
any way had to deal with that there
[ __ ] alrighty then I'm gonna trust
your judgment on them okay so I need two
key card for that one
I'm already healed up it's okay
all right thank you I was already pretty
much healed as it was though so really
you didn't do all that much oh hi hello
Val nice shotgun it didn't seem to do
you much good though I'll take it then
oh you did kill someone here though good
for you good for you
oh hi alrighty then some good food and a
sigh hypo behind that pillar doesn't
seem like a very useful thing right so I
can't get in there either dinner shift
begins at 7:00 p.m.
hmm ok so I have to find a way back up
but there was something about both
Alex's crew and my crew choreo those are
both things that I need let's see and I
wasn't able to wasn't able to unlock
that what's it talking about what door
oh that door ok that doesn't mean oh
good I could have locked it anyway
alright so I got to keep going up and
try to find a way I need I know I know I
need to go deep storage but I am going
to Alex's safe at some point and I know
there's got to be a way around this to
be able to get in there who looks like
that might be an elevator well oh ok
[ __ ] Jessica neatly doodly-doo oh
hello yes please can i yes I can you god
damn it not this again oh you so far
away you're so far Oh
yeah nah uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
tough they keep giving me the tougher
ones and I don't know why I deserve a
break every once in a while
I'm markiplier I'm that guy that you
want to help when you see me all the
treats right you're seeing his face
you'd be like and dumb that guy needs
help that's what you think right that's
what everybody thinks whatever fun in
the event of a loss of atmosphere
gravity or other curious emergency
please report to the monkey hey good
thing you came closer for a good old
scan all right let me just blew you up a
bit you look look - oh whoa oh god
there's two of you I don't like that my
odds got a lot worse all of a sudden
okay where's my my recycler charge just
gonna [ __ ] that right there Oh get
skadoodle
it skadoodle oh go come on come on what
you want your friends dead what you want
you got recycled bilge Oh get shredded
it okay so your dad do now so where did
your friend go so I can collect his
corpse cuz that's all I really care
about uh-huh where is he he got blasted
into somewhere damn he got blasted in
the next century I don't even know where
my recycler charged bits went god it
must have been after I dead detonated
the thing because it is all kinds of
gone out of here okay let's find the
elevator to go up this is the way to
deep storage but if I go yeah okay how
do I get in here level 4 level 4 ah
George a bunch of bull sure I don't want
to go to deep storage alright fine I'll
go to deep storage but only because I
want to and not because you're telling
me to it's how this works
all right what do we get here roof I'll
fix the elevator want to come back boo
this I can unlock cool that means I can
float around outside and get around to
the other places if I so choose
okay you seem very dead Heidi what is it
how's it coming I can't get this damn
thing open where's Danielle still not
answering
what's wrong then you'll tie the lock to
her voice we need her to speak the key
phrase oh we're not getting in here with
voice samples work transcribed
recordings yes if they have the right
words or if we gathered enough to map
her voice to a consonant and vowel list
and started running patterns I'll see if
I can find her or her transcribe I'll
check her room first
all right IV but look don't do anything
stupid Oh ivy Ivy [ __ ] no no where are
you send her to her death didn't ya all
right
wait Oh was this someone I'm supposed to
find Oh Oh hair harden baffles treasure
map mm I don't know what the Frick I'm
looking at here b2 b2 looking that way I
don't know it's unlikely chief Choe is
still alive I advise you follow Zachary
West strategy pack together voice
samples your transcribed is equipped
with the necessary software that's how
you made my voice Danielle's cabin might
be a good place to get started okay I
don't know where that is but I guess I'm
going there so did I get a key to go
into the crew quarters
oh hi you want to [ __ ] on me [ __ ] on me
[ __ ] on me huh bring it on
ha booth geeks last time I fought you
you had the upper hand but now whoa I am
about to top the last time you did
everything my shit-talking is a little
little less a little less profound when
I'm dying you want to you want to want
to you know try that again buddy with a
little bit of psychic power for you
where did you go huh whoa where you
going buddy
Oh get blue stood what's that your
thermal powers don't mean jack [ __ ] to
me cuz you're dead that's what I thought
yo li'l CH alright man I love that
kinetic blast that kinetic blast is
something I'll move it oh hello hi can
you fix me up I know I don't need it but
I just want to be a little fixed up also
I'm gonna jot down here to the bridge
just to see what's going on here before
I go back to the crew quarters just to
cover all the bases and make sure that I
got everything with the bridge oh this
is legitimately the bridge the bridge of
the whole ship well I don't need to go
there yet so let's just skedaddle back
until it tells me to once there's
something to find there maybe I can get
towels piloted back closer to earth
crash it into the mainland in fact
everybody with the talos virus and
everything will be hunky-dory or not
either way is good with me
alright so there's a whole bunch of
different things that I need to do
number one I need to I need to open so I
can make more neural mods period I need
to get that thing open so I can get to
that guy's workstation and then number
two I need to go down here and
synthesize a voice together which seems
like a lot of work and Ida I don't
really want to do that I'm a lazy kind
of sack of [ __ ] so maybe if you could
not that be also good too in the realm
of it being good did that make any sense
I hope it did maybe it did maybe it
didn't let's just see a little bit
farther about this uh-huh uh-huh oh
hello oh whoa hey hey hey hey hey hey
yes of course
ah [ __ ] are you kidding me
they're just sending people in to blow
up oh my god
what the [ __ ] hell this horrifying
stupid puppets what'd you do you want to
come into a kitchen good come
this is horrible this is horrible they
just get mind-controlled
me with them no I'm trying not do what
the [ __ ] that's horrible
you're out of Puppets huh maybe you'll
starve who are you talking to
how many bodies do we have uh I don't
know your doggie new oh oh oh oh let me
see if I ever geez out of here boskie up
nope can't do that okay I don't know
what's happening with that guy over
there but he seems to be very unhappy
about something or other at least I can
blast my way in here
oh man that's so sad they call out to
you they tell you not to get close
that's so sad and question I don't care
who you are that's the friggin sad oh
man why why is that need to be that way
this Oh what am i one of my least
favorite ways in any like movie death or
game death is like so much blowing up
out of their own control Julie that's
horrible
I mean it's quick and I guess painless
but still jeez alright anyway so I'm now
in the crew quarters but unfortunately
I'm all out of time for this episode so
let me know I'm doing the cabbage ball
and thank you everybody so much for
watching I'm gonna keep going on this
real soon so thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]